oh the halos will look for a bounce-back
performance
in game two of this three-game series
after losing a 9-8 slug
fest to the diamondbacks last night at
the big gay welcome to a beautiful
afternoon in southern california a
little hazy but certainly the temp is
up and the halos need to keep the temp
up inside
dylan bonding the angels ready to take
on the arizona diamondbacks in game two
of this
three-game set christian walker the
first baseman hitting 273.
and down goes walker a one two three
first we'll head to the bottom of the
first with no score
lefty caleb smith acquired from the
marlins at the trade deadline in the
starling marta deal
three innings against the mariners last
time out to a total of 40 pitches
29 of them for strikes very similar in
style to alex young
so they're on the corners with two down
for big albert
swing and a miss good slider there from
caleb smith and he strands two
no score after one sailing into angel
stadium
cole calhoun what a return last night
that's ripped into right field joe adele
is over there and cole calhoun has had
it again a lead off single
this is what he's been doing for the
better part of three weeks just
barreling up pitch after pitch
and here comes the freight train here's
another hard hit ball that rolls into
right field
and here comes cole calhoun he's in
there ahead of the throw
peralta sneaks into second and it's one
nothing diamondbacks rbi for the freight
train
as the first three have reached against
dylan bundy in the second
next batter up is ahmed he has been
outstanding as of late
ahmed dunks that one into left escobar
scores here comes peralta two-run single
for nick ahmed
and make it three-nothing d-backs and
bundy still does not have an out in the
inning steven vote now
vote spanks the 2-1 into right center
this will make it four
nothing steven vote with the rbi single
and the line keeps moving still no outs
in the second
max hitting 234 sassy drives one out
toward left field that's hit well moving
back on it
peralta that is gone big fly for max
stassi and i mean big
that was deep to left center field the
angels get on the board it's 4-2
diamondbacks
fletch lifted a fly ball to cole calhoun
in his
first half bound that is out toward
right center field
marshall will dive can't come up with it
back it up is calhoun fletcher's not
going anywhere
like dalton trying to figure out if he
likes the taste of that grass or not
and cole's like hey that's a pretty good
turf isn't it and marshall's going to
band with the bases loaded here in two
out
that backs up fletcher miller's got to
get over there they throw it away
peralta scores ahmed right behind and
it's six to two diamondbacks
a tricky play there for fletcher who
tried to make a spinning throw to miller
at first and threw it away
really struggled in his tent start to
get cincinnati or with cincinnati last
year after the trade just
cut on and missed and patrick sandoval
strikes out the side
pull it down that third base line just
like that
out it yeah they gotta caught it
on the ground and they get the double
play faces empty two down for jared
walsh who has singled the truck out
walls drives this one out to left field
that's hit pretty well moving back on it
is peralta that is gone
big fly for jared walsh's he goes apple
17 rbis in the month of september that
swing continues to impress
dalton marshall coming up the center
fielder
that's out toward shallow right field
the del broke back's got to come in on
it
and he'll go into the dive and make the
catch
nice play by joe adele two down covered
some ground on that one and now the
batter is up to where the base is empty
went to a fastball that is drilled out
to deep left field another home run for
the angels
it is six to fours nostradamus
tells this to swing first pitch and
justin obliges
back-to-back games for home runs for
justin upton cole
calhoun who's singled and scored in that
four run second he's one for three
this is lifted deep to center field
hoon welcome back cole calhoun his third
home run in this series against his
former team
and the diamondbacks have an 8-4 lead
one out now for peralta
and that one is off and deep
and way gone peralta's second in the
series
he homer in the eighth last night
against matt andres tonight he takes
sandoval deep in the seventh
and make it nine to four trout coming to
the plate
that is drilled out to center field
that's gonna get down and go for extra
bases
one hops defense simmons will score
easily walsh is on his way to third
he'll stop there and it's an rbi
doubled and it's nine to five and the
angels have runners at second and third
varsity he got it dalton varshall a
diving catch in left center
shroud now is on first for rendon
this one for ahmed they go the short way
and crichton
gets the job done again diamondbacks
clinches series victory